OK, speaking of self-inflicted disasters for
Donald Trump, yesterday, Donald Trump shared
a video of a supporter of his yelling white
power at protesters in a Florida retirement
community called The Villages.
Trump thanked the great people supporting
him in this video, one of whom is an older
white man who yelled white power as he drove
by opponents of Donald Trump's in a golf cart.
It's sort of like the epitome of privilege.
A white guy in Florida in a golf cart driving
by protesters standing out in the heat, yelling
white power at them.
And Trump's exact tweet was, thank you to
the head.
Can you believe this is reality?
Thank you.
To the great people of the villages.
The radical left do nothing.
Democrats will fall in the fall.
Corrupt Joe is shot.
See you soon.
Here's the video.
Trump was resharing with that comment.
And you'll hear just I think it like the eight
or nine second mark.
You hear this guy yelled White power.
There you go.
White power, white power, of course, is the
calling card phrase of white supremacists
and racists all over the world that has been
for it for many, many decades.
So this quickly became another disaster for
Donald Trump.
He ultimately had to delete the video from
his Twitter timeline.
And the White House's explanation is Trump
didn't hear anyone say white power in the
video.
Now, when you look at the video, the white
power thing is eight seconds in.
Trump didn't see or hear anybody say white
power.
So this in and of itself is insane and crazy.
But there's an entire other part to this.
Over the weekend, news reports were published
in The New York Times that Russia was reportedly
paying people to kill U.S. and coalition sort
foot forces, soldiers, male members of the
military in Afghanistan and offering bounties,
offering cash rewards.
And the White House has completely fallen
all over itself, trying to explain this away,
saying while Trump was never briefed on it.
Watch.
The National Security Council had it, but
they didn't go to Trump because it didn't
seem credible or whatever.
First of all, if that's true, if it is true,
why didn't Trump get briefed in the sense
that even if these are such serious allegations,
that even if they are untrue, if it got to
the National Security Council, Trump should
have been briefed on it?
We're gonna deal with that more later.
But there have started to be claims made that
Trump tweeted a white power video to distract
from the Russian bounty's scandal.
And I have to tell you, I don't buy it.
I don't believe Trump's base cares about the
white power video.
And I don't believe Trump's base cares about
the Russian bounty's video.
I think this is just Trump being Trump.
It just happens that both of these things
happened at about the same time.
Trump's base either doesn't care or doesn't
believe that Trump is even racist.
It's not going to help Trump.
It's not going to help remove Trump to point
out that he's racist.
I don't think that that is really why Trump
would do this.
And Trump's approval rating is sliding, but
it's sliding because of the corona virus fiasco,
the economic fiasco.
Trump's reaction to saying let's respond to
police brutality protests by saying send in
the military and use even more force.
His racist dog whistles have been around a
long time.
They didn't hurt him in 2016.
I think that this is just Trump being Trump.
I don't believe it's oh, my God, this Russian
bounty story is terrible.
Let me tweet a guy saying white power to make
the news.
Talk about that.
I don't see it that way.
Let me know if you disagree.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
I look forward to hearing from you there.
And remember that you can get the daily audio
podcast which set new records last week, stunning,
powerful records.
You can get the audio podcast on any platform
you prefer.
I tunes, stitcher, I heart radio, Spotify,
Pandora, all of them.
It's available on all of them.
We'll be right back after this.